this final segment is Joel Goldwasser
she as a senior reporter for Kiplinger's
Personal Finance magazine there's
something called the credit card Act of
2009 and for those before we go into the
nuts and bolts of it what was the
purpose of this mainly it was to make
things better for consumers people were
very angry at the bank's they felt as if
they you know credit card rates were
going up no matter what that they were
being treated really poorly people were
getting interest rate hikes at you know
one on top of the other so they could
not pay so a relatively small balance
had escalated into an enormous balance
and people were feeling the pain and so
this is a congressional legislation
wasn't there less or at least some rules
put in by federal agencies we're good
that oversee credit cards and what are
the differences between the two well the
Federal Reserve Board has to issue the
rules that implement the legislation the
legislation has specific provisions and
then the Federal Reserve Board explains
how it all is going to work ah okay so
as far as the specifics the calls in a
broader category so I'll read some of
them you can just add I guess meat to
the bone so to speak one you already
talked about ban it would ban unfair
rate increases give us a little bit of
what would happen under this legislation
okay if you get a new card you have to
get a rate that will last for a year
except there are obviously exceptions
promotional rates must last six months
and after the end of that introductory
rate that your rate can automatically
rise if your rate is based on an index
and most cards are now going to be based
on some kind of index such as the prime
rate it can your rate will rise when
that index Rises you know no matter how
often that is and then the other thing
is that you know if you're 60 days late
paying your payment they can raise your
rate so I get a this is just for new
cards that people get not currently once
they already have when this new right
whatever is in effect right now because
the rules don't go into effect until
next month will stay in effect and so
they have to stay in effect at least
forty or a year after a year and listen
you get like a low rate to start off
with right and if you get that low rate
it's gonna last for six months okay and
so you talked about
it deals with something called what it's
called I guess categorizes unfair fee
traps is that the same thing as interest
or is there other thing or is that a
separate thing when it comes to fees
well there used to be things like you
know you paid your bill at 10 o'clock
and the bill would be due at 10 o'clock
in the morning your you know bill
actually came in and was processed at 3
o'clock in the afternoon you might be
charged a fee you paid by telephone
because you had forgotten and so you
wanted to make sure it got in on time
you might be charged a fee for that you
know those kinds of little niggling fees
are eliminated they can't do that if
your bill arrives by 5 o'clock in the
afternoon on the day it's due it's on
time if your due date is a weekend or a
holiday and your bill arrives the next
day then you know Monday morning or
Tuesday morning it's on time so you
can't get fees for those kinds of
actions and so are these when you talk
about the interest rate when you talk
about the fees are these only for folks
with I guess will be classified as those
with good credit or with that apply to
anybody regardless of what their credit
status is no those kinds of things apply
to everyone there are you know no
exceptions for that cut those rules
there are some specific rules for people
who have poor credit and who are in the
subprime category because those fees are
particularly onerous if you are you know
someone with poor credit or sometimes
even no credit and you have to apply for
a subprime card it can be extremely
expensive and the card Act limits those
fees to no more than 25% of you know
your total credit limit when you're
talking to subprime or what kind of
interest are you talking usually when
attached to these cards oh probably 18
20 percent one more thing as far as
because we talk a lot about details but
one of the complaints that have been at
least for those who hold credit cards is
information and how they get information
about their credit cards what does it do
for disclosure practices well that
should be much better the Act requires
that your statement be much clearer much
simpler it has to have a box in it that
tells you how long it will take you to
pay off your balance if you pay only at
the minimum rate and it has to tell you
what your monthly payment will be to pay
off whatever your balance is
within 36 months and who as far as and I
guess that's the assumption that most
people don't have that kind of
information at least don't know how I
know most people don't I mean there are
calculators on the web that you can go
to that will tell you that but in
general if you look at your credit card
bill it's not going to tell you if you
owe two thousand dollars it will take
you X number of months to pay it off if
you only pay this minimum payment are
banks required to lay this out and big
14 font printer can they send you
something that looks like junk mail and
say they've met their requirements and
you know some piece of paper with some
small print on it
I'm sure some things will be in small
print but that is supposed to be very
clear and easy to understand the Federal
Reserve spent a lot of time with focus
groups and studying it to try to figure
out how to make these statements much
clearer more intelligible and the
requirements are that you should be able
to read them and know what they say and
as far as the extending by that if
someone called their bank and asked for
these explanations is that because the
government requires someone on the other
end of that line to clearly explain in
English what this means as far as these
new rules regs regulations disclosures
fees that kind of thing well there is a
customer service number and you should
be able to get relatively clear
easy-to-understand answers from customer
service one more thing and this is a
topic that is known on this program for
many years how does it deal with
students do it well you will not see the
ubiquitous tables anymore on college
campuses offering you know free pizza
t-shirts or whatever if you sign up for
the credit card
this appointment of students they may be
unhappy parents may be a little less
unhappy in order to get a credit card if
you were under 21 you must either have
somebody co-sign the card for you who
you know has demonstrated the ability to
repay that debt or you must give some
kind of proof that you have the income
to pay that debt back and so does that
mean a parent's signature this yeah it
probably will mean that a parent will
have to co-sign the card if the student
is under 21 so with all these things
when do these when do these parts of the
rules take effect next month February
22nd and so as far as is that it as far
as
as far as the whole bill was concerned
when it was signed to the law that's the
only provision or is that are there more
rules to come down the line there are a
couple rules about credit card scuse me
not credit cards gift cards that go into
effect next August but almost everything
goes into effect now or next month and
the provisions about notice advance
notice the 45-day a notice of change in
rates went into effect last August Janet
sorry goal Joan Goldwasser is our guest
to talk about these new credit card
rules she's with Kiplinger's Personal
Finance magazine she covers these issues
and more as their senior reporter if you
want to ask her questions about it it's
202 737 triple zero two four democrats
202 737 triple zero one for republicans
202 6 to 8 0 to 0-5 for independence and
you can also send in your comments on
twitter at c-span WJ and email us at
journal at c-span org if I'm a bank that
are issues a credit card I'm looking at
these rules do I simply comply with them
or their ways I do and run around them
well the banks have been acting you know
since last May when the when the bill
was signed I mean and that's why many
people have already seen their credit
limits cut their interest rates raised
and changes in their credit cards from a
fixed rate to a variable rate the banks
have been preparing for this for months
why is the magic behind that fixed rate
the variable rate change over what does
it do well I mean if you have a fixed
rate you know what the interest rate is
going to be a variable rate obviously
can rise as conditioned economic
conditions in the country change and so
we can change from month to month every
six months is there a rule when it it
depends on what index I mean the prime
rate is one of the most common and that
actually has stayed stable for a very
long time and it's very low right now
it's only three point two five percent
but one assumes that it will rise as the
economy recovers what does it do for
programs like if you want to like
airline travel or hotel stays does do
these new rules affect those kind of
things at all well I mean the rules
themselves don't affect them but what
will probably happen is that those
programs will become a little bit less
generous the
banks are hurting right now I mean one
of the problems is that the percentage
of charge-offs which is when the bank
writes off your account completely
because you aren't paying is that a
historically high level right now so the
banks are losing money and because of
this they are obviously trying to figure
out what they can do and one of the
things that they are doing is adding
annual fees to credit cards and the
airline cards are ones that have
traditionally had fees and look for more
of them and they're also cutting back on
some of the rewards programs it takes
more miles to get a free ticket or
perhaps more points to get a free hotel
room they're just making them a little
bit less generous when you say banks
does this mean every type of bank in the
United States that are governed under
these rules well every bank potentially
could do it in general the big banks are
a little bit less generous and with
their programs and have higher fees than
the small banks or the credit unions I
mean as far as the new rules under the
credit card Act of 2001 is covered under
it smaller banks credit unions it
doesn't know that doesn't matter from
the response to these rules with a
smaller Bank a community banks say this
is agree with it as much as a larger
bank would I guess no one would agree
with it but would they say they're being
unfairly treated because of their size I
don't know whether they'd say they're
being unfairly treated I think they
probably have not had the same kinds of
pressures because this you know the big
banks are the ones that issue the most
credit cards and that probably were the
most liberal in issuing credit cards to
a greater number of people I think the
community banks would say that they have
always been a little more careful in
whom they make loans to and a credit
card basically is alone so that they
probably don't have the same problems
that some of the big banks do Turkey
Village Arkansas Robert on a Republican
line you're up first
yes you're on sir go ahead I was
wondering about the credit card interest
rates as she was speaking about this
moment ago how they would raise them no
matter what your credit would be is this
going to stay into effect after the new
law goes in or will they actually drop
back down to whatever the primary
or because like mine I have the great
ready but every credit card I have has
gone up into the double digits over the
last six months well your interest rates
will probably stay where they are if
your credit card issuer raises your rate
because of a change in your credit
conditions if it determines that you are
a less creditworthy individual the new
rules require that they revisit that
interest rate after six months and see
if you deserve to have your rate lowered
and no one's quite sure how this will
actually work out but that is what the
law requires our next call is Jasper
Indiana Democrats line Michael good
morning good morning my question goes to
the balance transfer offers that to
credit cards make we recently took
advantage of a balance transfer with
Citi card and it was a particularly low
rate and we thought you know we'll
transfer this purchase onto this low
rate let it sit there for a while and
you know when we when we're ready to we
can apply some money to it and the next
billing cycle came through and that
balance had been reduced by the amount
of our previous payment we made a call
and found out that they were applying
payments to the lower interest rate
portion of our debt first instead of
applying at first to the higher interest
rate portion that we made purchases on
every month and that pretty much
obviates the whole point of doing a
balance transfer at a low rate
we weren't really apprised of this when
we took advantage of the offer and kind
of felt like we'd been deceived on this
and we're wondering what what will be
the new policy with regard to this sort
of thing well that is one ways where the
card Act really does make a difference
from now on when when the new rules go
into effect next month if you make more
than the minimum payment whatever your
payment is will automatically go to the
higher interest rate balance if you only
make the minimum payment then the issuer
has the right to apply it to whichever
balance it wants but if you make more
than the minimum payment it will go to
your higher interest rate balance
what will that do ultimately for a
balance as a whole well you'll be paying
off you know your higher rate balance at
whatever rate you're paying it off but
the you won't be accruing interest on
that normal you know before if you had a
zero percent balance transfer offer and
then you used your card and let's say it
had a ten percent interest rate and your
payment went to the zero percent your
ten percent interest rate balance was
accruing interest at ten percent so you
as he said you lost the benefit of
having this zero percent offer as a
couple of perspectives to these new regs
regulations we've invited two guests
that will join us during the course of
this segment the first is Josh Frank he
is with the Center for Responsible
Lending he is their senior researcher
mr. Frank you've done work on this
legislation ultimately what does this
mean for the consumer for the consumer
it means more honest and upfront pricing
they'll be able to understand their
credit card terms much better and know
what they're getting and it's a much
better environment for consumers and
what does it ultimately mean for the
lenders then especially from your
organization's perspective well the
lenders are still free to charge the
interest rate they want and they still
have a great deal of freedom so they
could get charged the interest rate they
want they just have to do it in a more
honest way so it means that issuers will
need to move to more honest pricing
however at the same time we just issued
a report called dodging reformers is on
our website www.levitt.com oops and
tactics to get around these rules such
as such as well we talked about variable
rates becoming much more prominent
there's manipulation of these variable
rates in a few ways one is they're being
set so that they even a prime does go
down the variable rates can't go down
they have a floor right at what they're
issued out so they're really only
variable upward the other thing they do
are increasing the number of issuers are
instead of fixing the index to the prime
rate right now there
reaching back and cherry-picking the
highest prime rate over a long period of
time and that can have a large effect on
consumers we estimated seven 120 million
and could be up to 2.5 billion in impact
as far as disclosure is concerned we
talked about some of the details but do
you think banks will follow through with
the spirit of what's being laid out
disclosure Wiser's in your opinion are
there other tactics that the banks could
use as well as far as disclosure is
concerned well I think there are going
to be some insurers who are going to try
to put use whatever they don't have to
disclose and try to use those to raise
their prices however I should be clear
then this was a very positive and good
law for consumers that will improve the
environment although it doesn't fix
everything disclosure will be better
although it won't be perfect one problem
with disclosure is that pricing is just
so complex in credit cards and that's
intentional and no matter how much
disclosure you have there's a limit to
how much the consumer can digest there's
a one-page summary of terms so so you
have a long terms agreement which could
be 40 pages but there's a one-page
summary that one-page summary can have
30 numbers on it in a typical issuers
agreement so the law will help because
it does improve disclosure but the
complexity is just there that makes it
hard for anybody to interpret was the
law in your opinion did it go far enough
as far as your opinion what was laid out
in it well in many ways it did however
as we see issuers are adjusting and
really the only way to make adequate
regulation in in this kind of
dynamically changing environment is
something like a Consumer Financial
Protection Agency which is curling under
consideration right now because issuers
are adjusting and the laws simply can't
adjust quickly enough there needs to be
a regulator who's dedicated to to
addressing these issues as they come up
and the regulators rule would just be
sure that the banks are holding by the
principles laid out in the legislation
exactly principle simply deemed that
pricing needs to be fair and front and
honest Josh
Frank with the Center for Responsible
Lending you talked about his research
you can find it on the organization's
website responsible lending org mr.
Frank thanks for your input this morning
thank you
he talked about the Consumer Financial
Protection Agency what's the status of
that these days or that effort by the
Obama administration well they're trying
very hard to get that legislation
through and you know there is has been a
lot of debate about it but because one
of the issues is there's so many
different agencies that deal with you
know consumer financial issues and that
this way they would all be subsumed
under one agency and how many agencies
are general I forget it's something like
a dozen I mean it's a very large number
and so that will boil it into one right
exactly
and that you know whose entire purpose
would be to watch out for the consumer
Augusta Maine thanks for holding we
speak to Gill on our independent line
yes like so many other people my
interest rate went up a seven eight
percent and it was due to nothing I did
as a matter of fact the letter I got
from my credit union a very conservative
outfit on Navy Federal Credit Union
the very first sentences said due to
recent changes in federal regulation
we're gonna have to recalculate your how
we figure out your interest and the
result of that was it went up by nearly
eight percent and they actually said it
was because of recent federal changes
nothing either I did so I'm wondering
what is it that changed that that the
federal government did that helps me out
by increasing lanes restraint by almost
eight percent caller can I ask just in a
general sense do you carry a balance
typically uh typically but I pay it off
from time to time it abscent flows
caller Thank You mr. Coldwater well the
banks you know as I said acted
prospectively they realized that they
were going to be impacted by the
legislation so one of the things that
they did to many
many people was raise interest rates
even for people who paid on time who
were very good customers now the
difference is that now you know they
won't be able to raise your balance your
interest rate instantly you know
overnight because you've done something
wrong I mean it's going to be a lot more
measured obviously people are not happy
and I can understand that fully when
they have their interest rates raised
but the bill does give them certain
protections that they didn't have before
and if they get to the point where
they're not happy enough they do they
have the option Schiff is closing
account and just making amends with the
banks sure right now and this provision
went into effect last August before you
know if your bank raised your rate you
you really didn't have too many options
now you will get 45 days notice and you
can pay off your balance at the old rate
either within five years or the bank can
require that you have a minimum payment
that's no more than twice what it was
before and so now the one caveat is that
you when you pay it off at the old rate
you can't use this card anymore so if
it's your only credit card you better
get another one you know in advance and
if a consumer went that route how does
that show up on a credit report it will
just show off it as pated as agreed it
won't hurt your credit score to have you
know it closed did the bill in general
do anything about credit scoring because
I know that there were some concerns
about how the various agencies that
involve themselves in credit score like
me you could have one score one agency
what does it is there a way to make it
more consistent or at least didn't know
I mean there's still there are three
credit bureaus and everybody figures out
the credit score in its own way the FICO
score is the most common one which is
created by Fair Isaac and you know
that's a private company and it will
continue to create its score using
whatever computer models it does and the
other credit bureau and the it sells it
to the credit you know the credit
bureaus but there are other scores that
are used and those are proprietary now
you can always get you can't get your
free credit score but you can get a free
credit report once a year from each of
the three credit bureaus and you should
always get a free credit report as
opposed to paying for one there's no
reason to pay for it
Palm Beach Florida jeanny on our
public in line good morning good morning
go ahead yeah I want to know if you have
an account a credit card or whatever a
loan line credit and it's paid off and
you want to close it is it better for
the consumer to close the account or the
wait for the company to close the
account for like non-activity
and how does that affect your credit
score it really won't matter who closes
the account if it is going to say paid
as agreed and you know fully paid-up
closing an account affects your credit
score only to the extent that it changes
the amount of your credit utilization
your credit card had a credit limit on
it and you were using some percentage of
that credit so when you close the
account that credit limit is removed so
you are using presumably a higher
percentage of your remaining credit
limit and you never want to use more
than 50% at the most and it's better if
you only use up to about 30% of your
credit limit so closing a card might
affect that and that would be a negative
San Diego California
Erica Democrats line good morning I have
a question besides credit cards which I
use and pay them off and I don't have a
huge problem so far but there was the
time because a cat as well I never
forget this there was underneath there
was an earmark that loaded guns in
national parks were now illegal and I've
never heard this mentioned again
anywhere in the Congress because I think
it was an outrageous thing to be passed
and I was wondering if it was ever
brought up again anywhere and if anyone
is fighting me
I wish you'd saying something about guns
there were guns in national parks
oh I did see something about that I
think that that was eliminated I don't
think it was an it certainly wasn't
included in the card act but I have a
feeling that they said that comes the
guns were not going to be allowed ever
in national parks but I I'm not an
expert on that so I know one of the core
if I go to a store and I have a debit
card from a bank sometimes I'll ask do
you want to debit or credit if I use it
as a credit does it apply under the same
principle as if I were to get an
American or an American Express card
from a bank or a specific credit card
from a V or any of the bank of these or
whatever do are those the same no a
debit card is covered under the
electronic funds transfer Act which is
another piece of legislation and the
rules are not quite as strict for the
issuers as they are under the Fair
Credit Lending Act fair Practices
Lending Act however I mean in general
your you are pretty safe using it I mean
there are certain protections but the
difference in whether when you use your
debit card whether you use a pin or sign
has to do with how much money it's going
to the bank is going to receive and how
much the retailer is going to have to
pay the visa or whoever is the bank that
does the processing if I have just a
strict department store card Macy's
whatever does that fall under yeah those
are yes those definitely will fall under
the rules those are our you know charge
cards credit cards and they cut our
covered Danbury Connecticut Frank on our
independent line go ahead good morning
good morning go ahead sir
please man yes you're on sir go ahead
okay good morning so sir you're on the
air go ahead with your question or
comment okay
I'm from Connecticut can you hear me yes
sir go ahead and I'm I received about
four or five credit cards so a couple of
years ago and I'm I'm retired
I'm on the social secur I'm on the hook
can you hear me sir you're on the air go
ahead please yeah what happened to me
was that I received all these credit
cards and I was wondering how come I
received these credit cards and I'm not
working well a few years ago banks were
issuing credit cards very liberally
almost anyone
you know would receive numerous offers
in the mail and they'd say you have been
pre-approved for this card and you could
it was pretty easy to gret it get a
credit card that has changed now partly
as a result of the recession and the
economy but also the credit card
actually addresses that and it says that
banks shouldn't be issuing credit cards
to people without having some indication
that they will be able to repay the
amount of money that they are borrowing
this is a more philosophical question is
consumer use of credit has it changed or
at least the because of the recession
because of hard economic times are
people using their credit cards
differently I don't know whether they're
using them differently i people are
definitely saving more people are trying
to pay down debt and trying to be a
little bit more careful in general
Thibodaux Louisiana good morning Paul on
our Democrats line and Paul if you could
turn on your television set that would
help I'm trying to find out something
about payment on a credit card if my
credit card limit is six $100 a month
and IP 200 and interest rate still goes
well well yeah if my flowers let the
poison one would come by and injury
would be maybe 15% and the next two
months even though I'm paying a hundred
thousand more than what they asked me to
pay its integrate good of twenty one
percent and now each month at the key
point up like that at the end of the
year I'm saying like seventy dollars
every three months on interest
I would give Boyd that let's go all
right that shouldn't happen anymore in
treaded issuer's will not be able to
raise your interest rate assuming you're
paying on time that in that respect I
mean you if you have a card your rate
should remain the interest rate should
remain stable I'm not quite sure why it
if you're paying on time if the rates
being raised every month but it
shouldn't be happening and it should
that should stop there's something
called double cycle billing what is that
and how does this legislation treat that
okay the legislation forbids double
cycle billing it's a it's a complicated
way of calculating interest where if you
pay on time one month but don't pay on
time the next month the interest rate is
calculated based on the previous month's
balance even though you paid off most of
it and and it ends up that it being a
much more expensive way for you to have
you know Oh interest but it that has
been eliminated as a February as of
February another perspective that we
want to bring into this conversation as
Todd Zwicky he is a professor in law at
George Mason University a school of law
mr. Sawicki what does the legislation we
talked about what it means for the
consumer ultimately what does do these
the legislation mean for the banks mr.
zwicki are you there yeah can you hear
me yeah go ahead good yeah I think what
a lot of your callers very reported this
and I think what both Congress and
consumers are finding out much of their
chagrin is that Congress can pass all
the laws at once but it can't repeal the
laws of supply and demand and I think
that's exactly what what we're ending up
seeing here is that III don't have I
don't know what the perspective from the
banks are I don't work for the banks I'm
interested in this from the the impact
on consumers in the economy and I think
what we're finding out is that while a
lot of these ideas may be well
intentioned or finding out is that
they're having a lot of severe
unintended consequences for consumers
that are resulting in less access to
credit higher interest rates rather
lower interest rates and all sorts
things that are going to end up
restricting consumer choice consumer
access to out to credit and so in the
long term people who need credit will
probably not get act not be able to get
access to it because these new roles
sure it limits the ability of creditors
some of the provisions are fairly
innocuous but some of the provisions
limit the ability of creditors to be
able to accurately price the risk of
card holders when circumstances change
it's pretty much I think anybody
understands that if I if the card issuer
is going to be limited in its ability to
raise a customer's interest rate when if
they become riskier clearly what they're
going to do is turn to higher interest
rate in the first place and that's going
to impact everybody both good risks and
in bad risks so a few ways of dealing
with these situations one is they could
try to price risk more accurately if
they can't price risk more accurately
what they have a second option which is
they can reduce their risk exposure
which means you just give people less
credit so in the end the beneficiaries
of this are not likely to be consumers
unfortunately it's likely to be payday
lenders and auto title lenders who are
going to be the people who are poised to
to a lend to two people who are not
going to be able to get credit now
because they've limited the ability of
banks to to price risk is accurately if
the otherwise might as far as the
provisions that require banks to better
disclose information to consumers is
that a good thing
sure in general yes I mean I've gotten
some of those things in and there's
really nothing wrong with that you know
the big problem comes when you start
getting to more arcane politically
motivated disclosures so for instance
your guest earlier talked about the
requirement that we've recorded there's
going to basically create more clutter
on your monthly on your monthly
statements such as requiring issuers to
disclose how long it would take you to
pay off your full balance if you only
pay the minimum payment studied by the
Federal Reserve a couple years ago by
Tom Thomas Durkin estimated that that
provision would affect about 4% of card
holders there's about four percent of
those in America who say that they are
interested
and knowing how long it would take them
to pay off their monthly their their
bill making the minimum payments if they
don't make anymore charges and that's
the last part is if they don't make
anymore charges I think it's a it's a
relevant question to ask whether or not
we want to impose more costs on issuers
and clutter monthly statements for
consumers to make it more difficult for
them to figure out what they need to
find because we think that four percent
of consumers might might benefit from
from that what do you what do you think
about our guests here in the central
t'me what happens to reward programs
what happens to points for Airlines that
kind of thing sure probably end up being
cut I mean what I mean basically the way
you can think of lending in general but
credit cards in particular it's kind of
like a balloon which is if you squeeze
on one part of the balloon it's going to
pop up somewhere else so that if you
reduce the ability to to adjust interest
rates if you reduce the ability to
charge fees based on consumers the
behavior and the cost that they impose
what you're likely to see is other fees
and interest rates adjust and the other
thing that you're gonna cause the second
thing that's gonna happen is that
they're going to reduce customer service
and the quality of cars including things
like rewards cashback and airline miles
and the final thing you're probably
going to see which is problem which i
think is the the worst of worst of all
is you're going to see higher annual
fees you see more annual fees recur and
annual fees are a particularly bad deal
for cooks for consumers because they
apply to everybody whether the good risk
or bad risk and the limits in determine
consumers from holding multiple cards
and the fact that consumers can hold
multiple cards is an incredible boon for
competition in the credit card industry
and if you if we see the realization of
annual fees I think that what we're
going to see is a lot less competition
and in the end that may be the most
far-reaching negative consequences our
previous guests talked about the need
for some type of legislature such as the
Consumer Financial Protection Agency to
oversee this and to ensure that these
rules are followed
would you support or
opposed such a move yeah the consumer
finance production agency is a
particularly bad idea if you anticipate
as we're seeing that the impact of the
credit card act Oh which is a fairly
mild piece of legislation overall but
but the impact overall that we're
already seeing is it's going to the
people are getting their credit lines
cut people are getting less and less
access to credit and it's exacerbating
existing problems in the consumer credit
market if what we're talking about is an
agency that would streamline the
enforcement of laws that would encourage
competition through better distance
there better disclosures and that sort
of thing I think that would be great if
we're talking about an agency that would
have far-reaching uncap and discretion
to to to regulate the substance of
credit card terms then I think we're
talking about a completely different
story I mean one example is the CFDA for
instance is it's currently composed to
have the ability to ban abusive credit
products whatever those are and I said I
think we see the problem as the card Act
has been implemented The Wall Street
Journal had an article a week or two ago
to talked about the new 79% APR credit
card what is the 79% APR credit card
that isn't a but that was a credit card
that was invented because of the card
Act it used to be that this was a card
that had loved a high upfront fees the
card acted your guest earlier said
limits the upfront fees that can be
charged on subprime credit cards so you
have high upfront fees and a nine
percent interest rate now they were
required to reduce the upfront fees in
charge of seventy nine percent interest
rate to consumers in order to make the
the product a feasible I don't see how
one could meaningfully talk about one of
those being more or less abusive than
the other it's an incoherent concept and
it just shows the way the CFDA is flawed
it's core in creating a sort of super
regulator that's going to look over
consumer shoulders and and you know
protect them from from from their their
own choices so I think while we need to
have
more streamlining more coherent
enforcement I don't think that it's
going to help consumers or the
economic recovery to drop a giant new
bureaucracy in the middle of that with
huge on cabin powers Tod's wiki George
Mason teaches law there at the school
law thanks for your time this morning
my pleasure Tampa Florida thanks for
waiting
Peter on our independent line go ahead
yeah I have two questions one for credit
cards to credit cards of with the same
bag Citibank I wanted to go in and merge
both carts one has a high limit one has
a low limit I'm going to merge both
cards they're both master cards and the
bank told me if they couldn't do it
because of the federal law the new
federal law and the other question I
have is why should I be penalized if I
keep a zero balance if I pay off my
credit cards every month why should I be
penalized as far as my credit rating is
concerned all right thank you and I'll
take my answer off the air okay but he's
not being you're not being penalized in
terms of your credit rating I assume
you're talking about closing one of the
accounts and having your credit score
changed actually I mean FICO scores are
an algorithm that is designed to predict
whether you will pay your bill and I
mean that's it has nothing to do with
anything else except this mathematical
probability of whether you will pay your
bill part of that is your payment
history and that's a large part of it
actually
but credit utilization is another part
of it now any of your payment record
when you close a card still stays on
your record for a very long time we're
talking you know seven to ten years so
it's remains there and it won't penalize
you really
it only has a very small effect and the
only reason it would have a large effect
is if you know this card has a very high
credit limit and you were using most of
your credit and then you remove this
so you were spending a lot of your
credit limit you were you know almost up
to the maximum and then you take it away
so that you are using a very high
percentage but otherwise closing a
credit card does not have a significant
effect on your score one more call
Tucson Arizona Steve on our Republican
line good morning a lot of my question
has to go along with last caller
actually in the credit utilization to
make a long story short I got roped into
a credit card as a college student in my
early 20s and branded up to about some
thousand dollars in debt for a twenty
year old that's a lot of money I
eventually got that all paid off over
the over many many years and last year
finally got that all paid off I closed
the account now and along with all my
other accounts that I have no credit
cards now now I have a harder time
getting any kind of credit because I
have no credit now in the past if I
would have had an option of $10,000
worth of credit I would have had a
better chance at getting a credit card I
think the system is broken on those
terms like that you know if I now that I
have no opportunity to run up a bunch of
debt I cannot get any kind of credit but
in the past when I could run up a bunch
of debt i had options in credit I'd like
to hear the experts opinion on this
thank you very much it can be a problem
in order to have a credit score you need
to have one open account and it has to
have been open for six months and that
is the minimum for FICO to calculate a
credit score and if you don't have any
and you can also it doesn't have to be a
credit only a credit card you can also
have you know a car loan a mortgage or
some kind of personal loan that has also
been open for six months and and for
which there is a payment record now if
you have none of those things right you
will have trouble and when you go to
apply for credit there's no question if
you have closed all your accounts you
don't have a mortgage you don't have a
car loan and you suddenly decide that
you need credit you will be in trouble
in and if you know that's going to
happen it's probably worthwhile to try
to get a credit card and have
established a payment record so that you
do have a credit score and you you know
can prove that you were a credit worthy
individual
Joan goldwasser is the senior reporter
for Kiplinger's Personal Finance
magazine Kiplinger comm / magazine if
you want to check it out on the web and
find out her reporting on these and
other issues miss goals walk gold law
sir thank you so much for your time
happy to be with you